коли
синьо-жовтий стяг залити кров'ю кров'ю
наших захисників зокрема він стає
чорно-червоним це земля і кров які
допомагають нам виборювати сьогоднішню
українську незалежність тому День
Прапора він і радісний сумний водночас
за цей прапор ми віддаємо занадто багато
життів ми проливаємо занадто багато
крові і в цій національно-визвольній
боротьбі та й зрештою за усіх багато
століть нашої національно-визвольної
боротьби і тому би хотілося щоб зокрема
і тут на Майдані не ходили оці всі
Торгаші з псевдо стрічечками і
браслетиками за які вони збирають собі
гроші а невідомо куди ці гроші йдуть А
щоби для кожного українця український
прапор був насправді святим його не
розмінювали на базарну мішурух а
цінували і розуміли скільки крові він
вартує